mm-hmm
folks
hey everyone
happy new year
the admiral's in the house
hi sir how are you
well
since we're more than 10 feet apart
while we're speaking we're going to take
our masks off
and uh let me begin by saying good
afternoon to my team
good afternoon the press and good
afternoon anyone who may be listening
i'm about to receive a briefing
from our coven 19 team
but before i begin
i know there is a concern and some
considerable confusion
about the rising cases so let me provide
a quick update
and talk about three specific topics
and i'll give it to you straight as i
promised you i always would
we're going to see as you all have been
hearing continued
rise in cases
omicron is very transmissible
transmissible variant but much different
than anything we've seen before
and but you can protect yourself
and you should protect yourself quite
frankly get vaccinated get boosted
there's plenty of booster shots wear a
mask
while you're in public
because what we know is this
the impact from the rising cases depends
on the effect on the person based on
whether that person
what their vaccination status is
you can control how big an impact
omicron is going to have on your health
if you get over omicron
you know they're
those are fully vaccinated especially
those of the booster shots and by the
way we have booster shots for the whole
nation okay
we you can still get covert
but
it's highly unlikely very unlikely that
you become seriously ill
and we're seeing covet 19 cases among
vaccinated workplaces across america
including here at the white house but if
you're vaccinated and boosted you are
highly protected
you know
be concerned about omicron but don't be
alarmed
but if you're unvaccinated you have some
reason to be alarmed many of you will uh
you know
you'll experience severe illness many
cases if you get covet 19 if you're not
vaccinated
some will die needlessly die
unvaccinated taking up hospital beds and
crowding emergency rooms and intensive
care units that's displaced and other
people need access to those hospitals
so please please please
get vaccinated now
you know we've reduced the number of
american adults
without any shots from 90 million
to about 35 million in the past six
months but there's still 35 million
people
not vaccinated
and let me be absolutely clear
we have in hand all the vaccines we need
to get every american fully vaccinated
including the booster shot
so there's no excuse
no excuse for anyone being unvaccinated
this continues to be a pandemic of the
unvaccinated
so we got to make more progress
and for patients who still haven't
gotten your kids vaccinated please get
them vaccinated look out for their
interest here
it's the best way to protect them
and for parents with kids too young to
be vaccinated
surround your kids with people who are
vaccinated
and make sure you're masking in public
so you don't get covet and give it to
your kids
look
we have no reason to think at this point
that omicron is worse for children than
previous variants
we know that our kids can be safe when
in school by the way
that's why i believe schools should
remain open
you know
they have what they need
because of the american rescue plan or
the first month we were in office or
second month
that i signed in march we provided the
states
with a hundred and thirty billion with a
b
billion dollars
to specifically keeps our students safe
and schools open
funding for ventilation
ventilation systems in the schools
social distance in classrooms even
larger classrooms on buses and
everything from bus drivers to buses the
the actual bus
there are additional
in all this process we also back then
include an additional 10 billion dollars
for testing for schools
that money went out to the states
and
the states and the school districts
have spent this money well many but
unfortunately some haven't
so i encourage the states and school
district to use the funding that you
still have to protect your children and
keep the schools open
countries across the world are seeing
rising cases
here in the united states our team has
been working around the clock during the
holiday weeks
in the last two weeks we have developed
hundreds of military that we have
deployed i should say hundreds of
military doctors and nurses to staff the
hospitals in our states that are overrun
and overworked because of one vaccinated
covert 19 patients primarily
the federal emergency management
association agency fema
is also working in our direction in
every state
and hospital capacity
including whether they need beds
i've directed fema to be ready to
provide emergency hospital beds wherever
and whenever they're needed
the federal government will be there
we've shipped nearly 2.4 million pieces
of protective equipment to hospitals
from gowns to gloves
and we're doing whatever we can to
protect communities from the surge of
hospital cases that are likely to see
from on back from the unvaccinated
population
look
now let me address three specific
updates before i get my
full brief from my team
first booster shots
i know
dr fauci i'm like an echo chamber here
okay i know it
but
repeating myself but dr fauci said it
very clearly
booster shots work
they significantly increase the
protection they provide the highest
level of protection against omicron
americans uh we've given out
over 70 million booster shots
importantly two out of three eligible
seniors have received their booster
shots
booster shots are free
they're safe and available
over 90 and over at over 90 000
vaccination sites let me say that again
for free available
and at over 90 000 sites
we have added sites added hours added
appointments added walking capacity
we have booster shots for every american
in the country
it's easier than ever to get a booster
shot and more importantly than that than
ever has been
look the fda has also now authorized
booster shots for children ages 12 to
15.
so with the final approval from the
center for disease control and
prevention the cdc
young people when that occurs young
people ages 12 to 15 will be able to get
booster shots later this week
second on testing
i know this remains frustrating believe
me it's frustrating to me
but we're making improvements
in the last two weeks we've stood up
federal testing sites all over the
country we're adding more each and every
day
google
quote covet test near me
go there google excuse me kova test near
me on google
to find the nearest site where you can
get a test
most often
and free
look
with more capacity for in-person tests
we should see waiting lines shortened
and more appointments freed up
look if you want to test yourself at
home
we have three options now one
drugstores and online websites are
restocking
two
you know well actually so the more tests
are available we're going to continue to
become available
next week
our
our requirement that your insurance
company reimburse you for at home test
takes effect so you don't have to
get reimbursed
so if you're insured you can buy the
test and get paid for it
the second thing i want to mention is
many states and local governments and
health care providers are passing out
free at-home tests that you can pick up
just find out where they are
and finally as i announced recently the
federal government
is launching a website this month
where you can get tests shipped to your
home for free upon your request
the third point i'd like to speak about
is also
is on
treatments
for those at high risk
who do get covet 19
we now have a new pfizer pill that
greatly reduces the risk of
hospitalization and death i'm pleased to
say
that on christmas eve
we shipped out the first batch of these
pills that we received we purchased and
received
and more will be shipped this week
we're all ready they're already saving
lives but due to complex chemistry of
the pills to make the pill
it takes months literally to make a pill
but production is in full swing
the united states has more pills than
any other country in the world and our
supply is going to ramp up over the
coming months as more of these pills are
manufactured
today
i'm directing my team to work with
pfizer to double our order from 10
million to 20 million treatment courses
to be delivered in the months ahead
we may need even more
that's the estimate we need right now
we've already placed the largest order
in the world
now i'm doubling that order
these pills are going to dramatically
decrease or decrease hospitalizations
and deaths from cover 19.
they're a game changer
and have the potential to dramatically
alter the impact of covert 19 the impact
it's had on this country and our people
look let me conclude with a quick recap
if you are vaccinated and boosted
you may get coveted but you are highly
protected against severe illness
schools can and should be open this
winter we have all the tools to keep
kids safe
unvaccinated kids are at risk
yet the vaccinated
are going to the best way to protect
them get vaccinated
if you're vaccinated get boosted
folks
i know we're all tired and frustrated
about the pandemic
these coming weeks are going to be
challenging
please wear your mask in public to
protect yourself and others
we're going to get through this
we're going to get through it together
we have the tools to protect people from
severe illness due to omicron
if
people choose to use the tools
we have the medicines coming along that
can
save so many lives and dramatically
reduce the impact that covert has had on
our country
there's a lot of reason to be hopeful in
2020
but for god's sake
please take advantage of what's
available
please
you're going to save lives maybe yours
maybe your child
please take advantage of what we already
have okay
so thank you now i'm gonna get this
briefing started thank you very much
thank you
you can just drop it
you